by the year 2050
we are projected to have
15 billion people living in the world
and apparently two-thirds of them are
going to be living in cities
that means we need to be building
approximately how many was that um 13
000 structures every single day and i
think if we want to move towards a more
sustainable future we really need to
change the way we build fast
by adopting new technology and new
processes last month autodesk invited me
over to their gallery in san francisco
to check out some of the projects that
are pushing the boundaries
not just in design and architecture but
in different fields i'm not gonna lie
like some of these projects really got
me excited and hopeful about the future
[Music]
a project that i thought would really
revolutionize the construction process
is from a company called scaled robotics
which is based in barcelona spain so one
of the biggest surprises for me when i
started working in architecture
and started going to construction sites
was the sheer amount of reliance on
manual systems and processes
to make very complex buildings there's
quite a lot of processes in architecture
that is like this but this especially
feels like a very old way of doing site
reviews and i feel like as buildings get
more and more complex it's going to get
harder and it's gonna get more
time-consuming and probably more
dangerous for architects to go and
manually do site reviews so this machine
from scaled robotics drives around a
construction site and it scans
everything and this data is uploaded to
the cloud and automatically compared to
the bim model and it automatically
generates reports and deficiencies and
percentage completion and it's able to
get a level of precision that i think
will be very difficult for a person you
might be saying lidar scans isn't
anything new it's been available for a
long time and you are totally right but
i think the magic is in the software and
the cloud-based nature of this i've
worked on projects where i had a lighter
scan model available
but the models were so heavy and slow
we still had to like manually go in and
model all the elements in revit yes like
it makes the model more accurate but
it's adding so much more to the work of
an architect and so this
product i think increases the level of
precision and it actually saves us time
and i think this is actually really
critical when you're developing these
new technologies as an architect who's
actually in the office and like doing
the work and like drawing the building
i'm sometimes weary of new products
because when a new technology comes in
it increases the output but it also
increases the expectation and as a
worker you're the one who has to produce
the work to meet those new expectations
so something like a lidar scanning
system that detects the construction
deficiencies is great
but if you're still the one who has to
log all that and fix all the problems
you know that's on you and it's adding
more to your workflow so when you see a
product that solves the problems on the
front end and on the production end of
things you know that it's been designed
with the architect in mind that's where
it gets me really excited so this
product was designed using bim 360
forge and inventor
[Music]
over here you see a scale model of the
nest building in zurich switzerland they
do research on new technology materials
and new systems they use recap to create
a digital replica of the building
and they basically place sensors
throughout the building which feeds data
to this digital twin and you can run
simulations on the co2 level or the
energy consumption and you can use this
to give you insights into things like
the maintenance cost or the comfort
level buildings produce 40 of the
world's global emissions
and with the ability to analyze and
evaluate and predict and monitor new and
existing buildings with such a simple
and intuitive interface
we can make better decisions on how we
design our buildings and we can kind of
better inform the stakeholders on where
and how to spend their money so this was
done using recap bim 360 revit and forge
[Music]
they didn't just have things on
architecture but on space exploration
animation transportation
for example leica animation studios use
the autodesk software to design and 3d
print thousands of variations of
expressions of the puppets they used in
their stop-motion animation
they also had an installation showing
their collaboration with nasa jpl
where they use generative design
technology to create a lander they also
worked with hyundai to develop a walking
vehicle that can adapt to different
types of really complex terrain
so it can actually access roads that
normal vehicles can access throughout
the exhibition you're going to see some
cool interactive installations and
role-playing games that's going to let
you experience the different parties
involved in the city planning process
and you can play with other people in
real time
so there were quite a few projects using
generative design technology
which is where you can set up the
parameters like constraints material
properties or even manufacturing
processes
and you can use the software to optimize
the 3d model
the projects here weren't architecture
projects but they had some in aerospace
and in the automobile sectors
and using the aid of ai they were able
to seriously reduce the mass of these
machines it's interesting that in both
cases it's generated a very organic
shape which is why at first i was pretty
skeptical about the application of
generative design into architecture
because architecture is an industry
that's very tied to the materials and
labor that's already available which is
also why most buildings look the way
they do but i learned from the autodesk
team that you can actually set the
constraints to only use traditional
construction methods and they've
actually worked with clients to design
buildings that still look very
traditional from the outside but they
used generative design to really reduce
the mass of the building components the
area that got me really excited was how
it could be used in the earlier design
processes generative design can help you
design the perfect floor plan which is
actually how they've designed their
offices in toronto
or the size or the placement of the
windows or houses or entire
neighborhoods to optimize for things
like natural daylighting or ventilation
or access
i'm sure you've heard the stats
buildings produce 40
of the world's global emissions and at
this rate we need to be not only
designing better smarter and more
sustainable buildings but we also need
to be drastically improving the process
in building these buildings if you want
to learn more about the software that i
mentioned in this video check out the
autodesk website and if you're in the
bay area i would highly highly highly
encourage you to visit the gallery for
yourself when they open i thought the
exhibits were really well curated and
seeing the developments in different
sectors it really helps you see what's
possible
and what we as architects need to push
you know architecture is and it kind of
has been a little bit behind i do feel
like it's one of the few industries that
hasn't been drastically transformed by
technology
and i really hope that in the next few
years maybe in a couple decades we will
see a big transformation in the way we
work i think i saw a glimpse of that
here so thank you autodesk for hosting
me and i'll see you in the next video
bye
[Music]
i've been working on something very very
exciting in the background i announced
in my last q a video that i'm taking 50
volunteers to help me
test the waters with this idea for a
discord community i think over the past
couple of weeks we've kind of
finished building out the foundations of
this and it's given me a really good
glimpse of what this community could be
and i'm really really really excited so
all of this is free for you
but if you want to join in on live video
or audio calls with me
a membership tier is available
where i'm going to sit down and answer
any questions and also be doing
interviews with industry professionals
for our very first week we've got an
interview scheduled with evelyn lee
who's been on the channel before but
she's been such an advocate for
architects over the past 20 years i
think she's one of those people who's
gonna really help transform the industry
and take into the future i am really
excited about that so i am gonna make
these interviews publicly available on
my youtube channel but they will be
edited and condensed versions designed
for youtube with this membership tier
you're going to get access to the full
in-depth and unedited versions of the
interviews
with the opportunity to ask
questions live that's the end of the
announcements i'll leave the link to the
server in the description as well as the
link to the membership tier and when you
join the server read the rules follow
the instructions please and go and
introduce yourselves so yeah i'm gonna
i'm very excited i'm looking forward to
meeting all of you excited i'm excited
you excited i'm excited are you excited
i'm excited i'm very excited